then we have a special treat to you
tonight our good friend Stephen ho has
been here many many times over the years
to instruct me in the art of combat
tonight he is back to assess all that I
have learned please welcome professional
stuntman Stephen ho Stephen thank you
now Stephen we have worked together
countless times over the years recently
we filmed a comic-con fight sequence
that I did with Andy Richter I thought
was a big hit we and you helped me
prepare for that we have a clip take a
look
pretty good
pretty good I thought I looked pretty
convincing I think I've learned a lot
and I think I've pretty much mastered
the art of self defense how do you think
I'm doing it was a it was a complicated
fight yep your stunt double did an
excellent job there were smart editing
the photography was you know obviously
excellent [ __ ] I thought I did a
great job you guys seriously I thought I
did an amazing job I think I was playing
my a-game and what do you think the
problem is you had a you had great
close-ups yeah I think your basics were
lacking and I what do you do this when
you talk about me
this is not how I know one sees me like
this in the world dude okay they do you
have like a no elbows pileup is not true
you know wow you're pissing me off a
little bit I used the whole body I have
a long body and I have a lean body I
have a sexy body and I have a body
that's ready for punishment at any time
okay so what you just put me through my
paces today I just urinated
and I'll be ready to go okay I think we
should work on basics and get back to
basics and make sure baek's is very
strong okay you can defend yourself in a
situation thanks taking my watch off -
there you go
why don't you start off on your back
right here that one doesn't want to
fight I think when we put your legs up
like a wishbone and let me inside there
what are you just like that how is this
a fighting technique we're gonna work a
lot of your upper body oh so now when I
forward all I want you to do tell you
what is this today just shimmy your
shoulders back talking too much
all right in the back then back the
other way you go what is this doing I
was just doing anything or engaging your
core what did that do that proved
nothing
your shoulders are much looser no
they're not okay let's go and sit down
now my ass is on fire
all right what are we doing Nana sit
down and get our legs warmed up so all
right go down to a straddle split in the
spread your legs
make sure you have to do it I know how
to do it let's see let's see so what am
I supposed to do this get into Sal's flu
chance here yeah
spread out don't even yeah okay back to
the front and here there you go fold in
the center now right hold it there or a
bad guy an ecologist is what you are
hold your legs up to the center yeah
and pulse okay okay great you're just
you know what you're just a perv those
none of that was a warm-up for anything
but I feel good
why aren't you ready to go so let it off
we're gonna teach you to go to
combinations in a street fight that you
can use okay the first one going back
here no elbows style of fighting we want
to capitalize on that so I'm sure you've
been slapped
why would you assume I guess I have been
slapped but why would you assume I've
been slapped people okay all right I
don't know so let's start from this wall
we just take a second I love this guy
this is it what a claw effect yeah this
guy's spoiling for a fight he's so angry
because he doesn't have hands that's why
all right so let's start this
combination from what we call a garden
on guard position
where it looks like you're being passive
but in reality it's a great defensive
stance okay right so we'll go from here
and instead of a slap we'll make a bear
claw so you make a fist like this get
your thumb to the outside and we're
gonna strike right there okay okay
your hands are up you don't want to
fight but then if you have to you get
the first shot in okay back off and then
you can get your push kick okay show me
the push kick what do I do
done this many times before it's right
seven years you should know by now
bottom of the foot and push your extra
pricky tonight I don't know what I don't
know what's going on all right here we
go all right so what I do is I start
with like hey I don't want any trouble
or fight and then I make there okay
I don't want trouble BAM come on hey I
don't want any trouble
BAM
[Applause]
okay
get out of here get him out of here okay
put Trump says to people at rallies get
it out of here
all right so now you have that go-to
combination then the next go to
combination is the same thing yeah but
it's going to be a go-to bearpaw to a
double leg takedown okay so I'll show
that on you first you're gonna take me
down yes okay we these guys in the
audience they're gonna kick they're
gonna pet you so you don't hurt yourself
oh okay
they're gonna catch because you gonna
really take me down yes sir okay so
we're just gonna go right into it okay
what happens so the first I'm gonna fake
I'm yeah hey there I reach under okay
right that right in it so normally you
would be in the air right okay then you
would fall down right and then from
there you can control the situation in a
full amount or half on whatever you want
to do okay okay would you like to try it
there's no need to put your hand on my
chest sir totally gratuitous okay well
this is a big guy who's this guy this
guy is so much bigger how are you pal
good to see you nice to see you I'll
look out okay
let's back up a little bit so you have
room to plow all right so the idea here
is they go for the strike but then
instead I do the takedown so three
things to remember you go for the strike
he checks up I okay just remember drop
to the crotch so Mike drops are you
looking at a lot okay I've been there
and done that
so dropped away out of you
now what happens if I drop down there
but then just get lost
[Applause]
I'm not saying I would do that but one
might do that okay so then don't keep
your eyes there right maybe look in a
different direction so that you drop
down then push forward see where my eyes
go now and I came this way right grab
right so your bear hugging and then I'm
snatched the same time you're going
forward right and then just thrive this
mofo down right so rocks hug nah
and then just gonna go with everything
I've got exactly all right so this guy
comes at me he thinks so there's Colonel
Brian never liked his show I'm gonna go
at him I'm gonna be like right yeah and
then I go like this
[Applause]
okay but what are you wrong it didn't
work because no I know it didn't work
because you had your head down here so
you're open for a guillotine so next
time get your head yeah bring your head
here put your head right to his armpit
right here right there so now you're
right there no look up look up look at
me hello right there right there okay so
now you're there so keep it that way
so keep your head that way right so you
grab snatch and then bring your head up
and then bring my head up yeah it's the
driving force to get on down okay okay
we'll try that again
hey guy I don't want to trouble a lot of
talk shows out there you don't have to
like them all
[Applause]
okay so next we're gonna mix this up on
you okay let's go back to kicks now so
Afghan Matt remember the combination you
should be on your toes ready for
anything
what are the combination we're gonna do
a bear a bear paw with right leg and
then we go right same thing we did on
Bob
from here to a push kick okay okay
choose both these guys one at a time
let's start on that first okay so it's
okay nothing happening sure throw your
body into it that was my that was my
entire body back not Ford back okay
let's go to watermelons watermelons okay
ever come up we've tested your agility
we've tested your speed now let's work
on your power with the Bear Paw okay so
now with the Bear Paw you just have to
have to give a good hit just like that
okay
to make sure that you see how I turn
right see how I turn my body why don't
you get into it no so it's sort of this
kind of thing right there
oh why I gotta climb on
okay band okay let's test it out go all
the way through turn into it
[Applause]
watch the hair
okay here we go slippery slippery floor
I'm gonna catch it your way by the tree
floor kick down the door five guys are
gonna come on I just beat a fruit salad
why do I have bad nose I want you to be
quick on your toes so what do I do you
kick the door down five guys attack you
do something that we've learned today
okay my question is if I'm kicking their
door down I'm in the wrong they have
every right to come out of there and
beat that [ __ ] out of me right that's
your house that's my house you're in
hello drew my watermelon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you